I'm live. No one say anything bad because I'm live.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm live. I'm live.
Okay, okay, okay.
What?
Is it going?
Is it working?
Oh!
I don't know.
You two have been kind of lagging in terms of like moving alive.
Yeah, it takes like a hot second for me to even
appear.
Like when I hit.
Guys, guys, guys, it killed my broadcast room.
What?
You killed your broadcast room?
Right now?
Like it suddenly like stopped streaming and then
my power wash simulator
replay deleted.
I'm live right now.
I'm live.
My chat is laughing at us.
Chat, I'm so sorry.
Hello, everybody.
We're so professional.
It's been awful.
How many VLR members
do you need
to do a collab to properly
do a collab to properly.
Merci. Well, I'll meet you in your room.
Yay, she might need a new room.
Hold on.
I'm just eating arrows called
leche live in life.
Sip in a ahoritos.
Hello, everybody.
I'm gonna go make myself some tea while we're living.
No.
Should I die?
Why?
No, you're okay. You can go make some tea.
She's like, I'm busy.
No, you can fuck this straight.
I'm gonna go make some tea.
You can go make tea.
That's fine.
Oh, we need to help Merci.
Why did this get first stream on?
Guys, we have been at this
for 26 minutes.
We were on Powerwasher
for one hour.
And every time we went past
four of the girls connecting,
the connection
started timing out for some reason.
But if for some reason
in Powerwasher,
if you haven't played the entire campaign,
it doesn't allow you to have
six persons in your lobby.
And I'm the only one with a finished save file.
And it was too late to
ship all the coding information
to send it on
on your stream.
Yeah.
And so basically,
Shebe rescued.
Shebe was like, right, I'll set this one out.
You guys just do it and we're like, no, we can't do it.
The whole point of this is that we're all together in this.
So then we're like, right, who's got Gmod, right?
I don't have it, right? Who's got RAF, right?
Who's got this game? I don't have it.
I was trying my best.
Shebe was like going through the list.
She was flicking them pages like, next page,
next page, next game, next game.
Jackbox. Okay, that won't work.
Literally.
We went, all right, we'll do Jackbox.
And then wait, that requires us
to screen record the discord.
I'm like, we can't have that. We see outrageous things
in the discord. We don't even have a HR department.
So we can't share.
So then,
we have a static phone,
which I've never played before.
It's coming in clutch right now.
Amy's currently making a cup of tea.
Merci
is just
getting
a room set up for her
because
she accidentally nuked her bot
of her
the collab stream.
It was a disaster.
This could have gone
any worse.
So just
I think that's like, pretty on character.
Yeah, if someone can insert
that meme and put all of her hairs on it
and be like, oh, aren't vTubers cute
when they're almost
or a little
That's all I'm going to say. Well, you guys
can finish the sentence after that.
But that was
I can't? No.
Not like that.
The three flings, the snowberries,
the billion hearts,
the harem, I remember I was like, okay,
I'm going to be honest when
the harem told me they were called harem,
I read it as harem and I was like, that makes
no sense for Shiby's character design.
I did too.
I was like, what?
I have a harem
of so many people
that are my little, you know, play things
and clients and they're my harem
and that's hair, which is a rabbit.
But it's not a rabbit. Hair and rabbit are different.
But you know what I mean?
It's a good pun.
It's a pun, exactly.
And they're also called harlets.
Individuals are harlets or harlets.
I thought you said hairless.
They're hairless.
Some of them aren't. I can tell you that.
Maryse, do you still have that
thumbnail, Maryse?
Are we good now?
Almost.
Maryse, do you still have
that thumbnail?
If you just throw up
on the stream.
Is she going to throw up on the stream?
Is it the are you and what are you streaming?
Yeah, it should default to that.
If you just change to the thumbnail
and put garlic on,
I'm literally telling
herself to stream whilst she's streaming.
I'm
dying.
I cannot read that.
Oh.
My goodness gracious.
When are they too loud?
Yeah, how's the volume?
Yeah, it's my volume.
Can you hear everyone else?
Who said the harlets
are waxed in my chat?
What does that even mean?
The harlets are waxed.
I need them to be clean and proper.
Volume good?
I see it.
How do I change the
garlic phone?
On managed broadcast
on OBS?
We're doing so bad.
They called.
We have the column.
Thank you for the 10
members.
10 gifts.
Don't gift right now.
This is awful.
Any gift?
2 o'clock.
Yeah, any gifters for my
non-monetized?
Oh, no.
She, me, and Azur aren't monetized yet.
Oh, my God.
I'm muted.
I was muted the entire time.
Oh, my gosh.
I can mute with her.
We heard you.
No, what is happening?
Oh, what is this?
What is this stream?
This is awful.
This is a
fever dream, guys.
This isn't real.
We're all in bed.
I don't have a garlic phone thing.
I guess I should change my stuff now.
What?
Why do we need to change?
No, you don't have to change anything.
As long as the game is on stream, you can change it after stream.
No one gives a shit what the stream is called.
As long as we're online right now.
Okay.
I'm just doing it.
The girl's running around
like everything's on fire and I'm like,
it'll be fine. We're good.
We're going to play some garlic phone.
We're going to have a great time.
I think the world is going to end.
Don't forget to like and subscribe on this stream
if you're enjoying your experience as a viewer.
Absolutely not.
Smash that bell to get notifications
of when you go live.
Smash that bell to get smashed.
I see.
Yeah, like with alcohol or something.
Yeah, I am.
Not literally.
I can't help myself.
You love smashing.
Like with the Nigel Thornberry,
she just says smashing.
Like that's it, you know?
Are we here?
are you here?
i'm barely here
i'm sorry for the mess
yeah we're here
i'm live now
we at Veilure have done the holistic approach
where none of us will mute
so you're just gonna hear
everything all at once
yeah
that's how we're all
just as a reminder
my memberships or super chats
will be addressed at the end of the stream
when it's not an absolute cluster
of all six of us together
but yes
the whole premise of the power washer
was i was gonna do a gag and be like
oh Veilure isn't doing so well
we might go bust so everyone
put a bikini on and get cleanin
well that idea is out the window now
so instead we're playing Gartik phone
i've never played it personally
she be
suggested it and i
her word is law so
let's just take it away
i'm taking over the company
i'm the shadow CEO
okay do you guys wanna start? you ready?
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
let's do it
let's go
what a sentence
i know cheating the guy is so chat
don't fucking cheat
don't fucking do it i swear it out beat your ass
i don't know
how long do i have to do the sentence
i don't know help me out
help me out
we flings don't give out way until it's over
this is our secret
oh wait
i'm in
hello
i don't think they'll actually know what that is
what's wrong
who did that
we have to draw these now
fuck
what is this
oh my god
thanks for the mouse
you brought that
this is so bad
oh no
i've never done this before
wait can i make my pen
smaller sheet
why is it getting transparent
i don't want to draw it
i don't even know what's happening
why are you guys screaming
this is oh my god
i don't like
how much time is left
the top right corner
the indicator
not the shading
i'm an artist
i wish i brought my drawing tablet out
an artist
oh yeah wait all you can draw about me
that's it you're all done
we're losing our mouse
oh my god
we need to do a witness stunt
hold on
i can't spell
what the fuck am i doing
what is this
shit
i should whip out my
drawing tablet for this
it's better with the mouse
better with the mouse
no it's better with the mouse
if it looks like hot garbage
it looks great
speak of done
i'm done
what's text say
can't tell you
these are items
okay that's all i'm saying
100% wood
why not
we need to put the chat logs in quick
should i make good
these are the chat logs
chat logs
what
you guys aren't ready for mine
let's put a bit of detail
we need some wood detail
americans always have an eagle
now it's your turn
to describe this being walmart
what the fuck
there we go
there we go what do you think
wait
my gen mates are wild
fuck
oh my god
i don't know what he looks like
oh god
hold on
she's been so far away
because i've wiped off my mic
oh right
i don't know what thornberry looks like
oh no
i had to look it up
i'm just guessing i'm just going for it
what did i look like
i look like this
oh wait i don't look like that
sugar
don't question
i got my leaner
my punches
don't question this
oh that's me
how do you draw a hegeo
i don't know
i don't know how to draw
i don't know how to draw anymore
that's pretty good right
you guys agree
i don't know
this is something
put a bit of ginger in it
and there you go that's me
i don't know what
that's your hair
this is not
this is awful
i'm sorry
this is
i don't know let's
let's draw some hair
oh my god
oh my goodness draw his thorn
i can't
has no one
just google it
i still hate the thorn rung
that is very nice
i'm glad you agree
my flings are saying i'm a true artist
wait wait no
emi's hair is not orange
is it emi's ginger
oh my god
are you a blonde
your hair is orange
i thought i was blonde
no
i've been drawing myself looking at this
what does that even say
oh my god
i was late
which one of you speaks spanish
because i was near
oh lord
what
oh how am i supposed to draw that
oh my god
did we even have
what am i looking like
oh wait i can't even draw the fucking toilet
alright hold on
what i even look like
this is terrible
on mouse
this is so hard with the mouse
wait this is not feet
this is armpits
we're like we're grabbing onto the ground
for dear life in this one
right armpits
so
i don't know
oh my god
just because none of you guys
know like some english phrases
or some jokie phrases
like what i'm hearing is that a lot of you guys
are misinterpreting whatever it is
and it's very funny
it's going all over his back
it's not looking good
how do you draw an angry mouse
like a
oh
and then
and we need
no our paints are our paints
we need to draw
beats of sweat
this is amazing
what does the walmart look like
your armpits
has become sentience
walmart
i'm not even gonna explain to mercy
what do you call it
i'm not even gonna
oh wait don't your toilet have like
a mouse
oh wait
i don't know
it makes it worse
oh my god
i can't
is this too funny
i'm perfect
i'm drawing an ink
i think it works out
the radiation
i can't wait to see everyone
now we get to see everything
now we can see everything
oh my god
Oh, there's gonna be no voiceover and then we'll be beginning from the end. Yeah
Okay
So let's see I see so I said I see with Nigel Thornberry's face saying smashing
Oh
Your please
It's so cute!
Oh, that's so cute!
I love it!
Thank you. Why is your O.G. kind of such a fat cock?
Do you think he's funny?
Because he loves me. And he's daggers and slicker with all the love he has for me.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Oh my gosh. I'm sorry. Man, it's so cheesy. Faster than feet.
I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know. I don't know.
I like that poem. I like that poem. I never was stinky Pete's.
Which is Pete's feet. Oh, may I say it to George?
And then she drew pits.
I can't see. I can't see. Oh my god. That's too good.
Pete's. She's cutting out. Yeah, she's cutting out from you.
He's screaming so loud. Oh, no, not this one.
Okay, I got it from AC now. I got it from fucking AC. Thank you.
What does that even mean?
When your job is a poo, so when your poo hits your prostate on the way out, it feels good.
I love hot pees too.
What is this?
Is Amy's stocking?
Every sucker on them hot toes.
Oh wait, is she giving a blow job?
That's what it looks like.
Percy, what did you draw?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my god.
I love the drills. This is so fucking good.
The drills are so good.
Oh boy. We are over some pie.
Okay. That's cute.
I love that. That's a really cute toy.
Is that a cat?
Meow.
Meow winky face.
Okay, it's a winky face. I was like, what is meow us?
I was like, who? No one speaks Spanish. I shouldn't hire anyone.
Speak Spanish?
You're so fucking cute.
Oh, that's good. That's good.
That's good. I love that.
Oh.
Okay, this makes sense.
This makes sense of what on earth we were drawing.
That's a check out and that's items on the shelves.
I worked really hard.
I didn't get that.
This is like a diaper.
I see you understood me.
Oh my god.
Oh, I love the details.
Shut up.
Seriously.
I was coming out of his back.
I was going everywhere.
I can't.
I had to do the toilet stall gap.
That's all I see about when I see American memes.
Oh, the toilet is taller.
The toilet is so big you can literally look at people's eyes.
Is it a different version?
We have them closed because it's a private time
and you're very vulnerable taking a big job.
It's actually closed everywhere else in the planet.
Oh, you're so lucky.
I had people peeking at me in high school through the stalls
and I'm like, can I help you?
Me too.
Is there a check?
Is there a DC check?
Are you in the lobby?
It's going to do it on its own usually.
No, I'm gone.
The link should be in the discord.
Don't show your fucking screen on the discord.
They'll see all of our naughty photos
we just sent to each other.
It's mostly memes.
I mean, to be fair, we did share...
We did share some funny memes.
We did share some lucky nudes of ours.
They see my titties.
I started roleplaying as the girls with my nudes.
I was like, this is what Emmy would do.
This is what AC would do.
The discord is so chaotic.
Also, I did snort out my tea.
It went down the wrong hole and went up my nose.
Wow, Marcy, I hear you snort in tea.
This is what you hear.
Gotta lay off that testosterone.
It hurts so much.
Are you in game?
I posted the link in the chat.
That's why you guys were in my arms.
I'm getting another heart beat right now.
Every time she talks.
Avatar nudes are eye around nudes.
What do you think?
Oopsie.
I feel like Azura could do a really good
Jennifer Coolidge impression.
Me too.
You don't know Jennifer Coolidge?
Jennifer Coolidge.
I'm such a big titty.
Oh my God.
Jennifer Coolidge.
That's so good.
Why are we opening our God for the left way?
You're a G-boy, they're Razzlers.
Azura!
Drop the base!
Blah, blah!
Azura, click that link in the general discord to re-add.
Is it not letting you back in?
Are you being re-gained?
No!
I'm not!
Eh?
What is happening?!
You're making...
Your make cuts out when you do that Azura, so it just goes
EW!
What's happening?
I don't even know what's happening anymore.
It's constantly loading, it says...
Did you?
No.
Right.
It's literally...
Let me do another invite and members.
I'm sorry.
Will you guys see the discord if I open it?
Okay, you guys can't see it.
No, if you do window capture...
I'm sorry.
It's open.
I shouldn't see anything else.
I would close the window capture in the OBS just in case.
Yes, you can open it off.
Are we starting a new lobby?
A new lobby?
I think we should all invite to this lobby.
A bit of a...
Lights are too heavy.
Are we going to a different room?
I don't know.
Lights are too heavy.
What is happening?
I only see one of you.
No, I'm on my end, sorry.
A new one?
Ah, there's...
Wait, my voice is in.
Where is it?
Okay, which one should we play?
Which one?
Normal.
Which we just did.
Knock off.
Keep yourself focused.
Try to replicate the drawings while the clock gets faster.
Create an animation in a collaborative way.
Icebreaker.
Play with a sentence.
Ask questions and have fun with other drawings.
Exquisite corpse.
Create surrealist characters connected by the top of the drawings.
Don't know what that means.
Hold on.
I have no idea.
Burp friends, have a good time with that.
Compliment.
Complete the sketch.
Start with basic lines and see other players' interpretations.
Masterpiece.
Create a piece of art.
Play in a single turn with no time limit.
I feel like story would be funny.
Write a narrative using only the previous sentence as a reference.
Yes, okay, okay.
Story, story, story.
Okay, okay.
You want to do story?
Okay.
Yeah, let's try story.
What are you doing?
Start writing a story.
Wait, do I have to write a full story or just a sentence?
Just a sentence.
Just one sentence.
Okay, okay.
Fuck you.
Do you like write the whole story or no?
No, you have really limited characters.
I don't know it.
No!
What did you do?
There's time.
15 seconds, love.
Oh my God.
I wanted to write more.
Only write one sentence.
Fuck.
All these stories.
Shit.
I feel like I should have drowned.
Dude.
What is this?
Something
Oh, oh the sentence is so small like I want to give a bit more
Me too, but it's too short
I think I got shorter over time
I want to be like bibe
I couldn't write until fuck
What?
What's that?
Okay
Wow, let's see
Oh no, what?
Fuck
Fuck, I'm so bad at this
I'm not soft neighboring
Fuck
Her name
It's funny because like
I hate this, I can't think of anything else
The regangs, the snowberries
Fuck my life
The pin pals
The bleeding hearts and the harem all get to see this unfold
And we're all just taping like
Fuck it, I don't fucking know
Wait, is that the fucking
You watch fucking Big Bang Theory
Wait, that's not how you spell it
Paris
Fuck
Give me more
I need more letters
I need more like
I can't find anything
What am I doing?
Writer
They can't spin song lyrics
They jerk so hard mother fuckers want to find me
That sounds like she made me
No
Did you hear it so hard mother fuckers want to find me
Wait
I don't know this lyric
This agency
We can't just
I spelled it wrong but that's the point
I hate that like they don't give you enough to write
Like
This is not enough
Bro, fuck off
Oh boy, okay, let's see what's happening
So how about everybody reads their own story
Whoever did the first line
Okay, cool
Okay
Oh, okay, I go first
In a galaxy far far away there was a goat with big titties
She had so much milkers and started raining milk
Azara then went home to make an empire being milked daily
It was so successful the neighboring kingdoms became champions
They also wanted so much juicy
Ew cooties, you're not good
Good, good, you're not good
Oh boy
Okay, long time ago in a chemical farm
Yeah
There was a polar bear princess who was trying to fit into
Their love was stronger than any foreign addiction
They couldn't stop chewing on themselves from drinking
They drink so high in my fucking stomach
I didn't know I would finish it
I was like, this agency, okay
Ding ding
That was supposed to be the song like ding ding
Oh my god
Ding ding
Balls so hard
Strani, who was in Paris?
I typed Azara
I typed Azara, I'm sorry
There was a beach of agency that was lit
They all couldn't control their urges to pass
So they danced the pee-pee dance until they could
And then finally they peed everywhere on the
Floor, the walls, the bed, the kite
We're all full of piss everywhere, but he loved it
The fact that there was not even a piss prompt before AC came out with that
Literally there was only AC came out with one
AC came out with one
That character added
This is so good
Okay
Once upon a time there were whores
They were the eliters of whores
A cow from the wild west
All the really cute cowgirl
Pussycat, so cute, so funny
So pussywarm
Big bang theory, more like bang bang your mom last time
You keep my mom out of your home now
I'm sorry
10 out of 10
Once upon a time there was a pig
Oh, no
Oh, no, okay, this one
Please, no
Oh, no
Oh, my face hurts from blood
Oh, this is so good
Oh, what the fuck
And now you guys know why I rate the scripts in Vila or nothing
Why?
Because we had a zero vote of each other
You were sad because you realized you didn't have a prostate
Why do I keep talking about shit all the time?
She became so bad
I hate this
Fuck, no
Pain
No, I didn't want to be pregnant by Sonic
Ezra, do you have a make filter on?
I can never hear you
Turn that mic
Get that SteelSeries
See that SteelSeries
I don't have a filter on
Don't have a filter on
There's no filter on?
What is happening?
Your SteelSeries filter
Open up
I don't have a filter
I definitely can't hear you
What is happening?
Can't wait for the VOD if they survive
Yeah, these VODs
They'll be fine
Don't worry about it
If you guys want to play this one
Or do you want to try another one?
Another one
Please, no more shit
No more shit in Piss
No more shit still
No promises
Should we do a compliment?
Compliment
Actions are a mystery
Drawings and sentences are hidden
You can't hear MercyTest
Sorry
I was muting because I was coughing
Because I was laughing
My sides were so badly
Okay, MercyTest complete
Do you want to do compliment?
What is that?
We draw on each other's drawings
Basically
I think that would be fun
Wow
I can't wait to draw so much piss
That's some basic lines
Start sketching some basic lines
Okay
Let me do this
Maybe I could do some basic lines
Like
Great, now I'm just going to draw a bunch of dicks
I just blew that
Picasso
Are you joking?
Who is that?
Fuckers
Do you know exactly what you did?
No, I don't have the strength to resist
What?
I got it, I can make this
I can salvage this
This is the back legs
of it
Those huge milkers
There you go
You're so dirty
Don't be so dirty
I'll get the girls to tell you off
if you don't behave
You guys don't have innocent eyes anymore
You're so dirty
Rude to me
Wait, am I supposed to finish this off?
Are we supposed to finish it off?
I think so because it's given us tons of time
Hold on
I fixed it
Hello
A big push up bro
Oh my god, I've just made shibby
What the hell?
I heard my name
Oh wait, that's the thing
Dang it
Give me the pencil
There you go
I saved it
They give you a lot more time
Yeah, you're to finish it
Okay, I'm fucking stupid
Never mind
So am I, don't worry
Saved it
Oh my god
Let's put some nice shading in
To make this look extra beautiful
Wow
Let's put lipstick on them
The beauty of nature
I think
I saved it
They prank him
I think this is the best I got
I'm good
Who drew a pair of hairy ball sacks?
Come on
What the fuck
What am I supposed to do?
Oh these are all
The shaft
Oh, I really know what I want to do
But I know I shouldn't do it
Because we're on YouTube
I'm fixing this
Oh no
I can't think of one thing
This is amazing
Oh wait, maybe
Hold on, hold on
I got it
Fuck, how do I go back?
Okay
They've got a big head
This is so fucking good
Let's fucking go
I'm trying so hard right now
I can't even think of anything to say
I'm trying so hard
Oh my gosh
Use your imagination
There you go
Look at you all
I'm so proud of you
I'm gonna kick your head
Alright
We need to be nice to the workers
Your lap is so cute
I see
Thank you
I love you so much
Aw, that's so sweet
I think I did mine really well
Yeah, it's a water bottle
That's the best I got
I need
I saved the pair of all sex
Did you make it into a dog or something?
No
I don't know how about you
Senpai, can you do better? Shut the fuck up
I love when you do that
Oh my god
What is this?
I got the pair of all sex
We can hold on
You're asking me not to draw the gynecologist
What do I do?
What can we do here?
How do I make this? How do I save this?
I need to do this
I need to do this all for a minute
Okay, I won't draw that
Cause that would be
Oh my god
I just realized
I'll draw this in the stud
I'm gonna fucking snip it
From Star Wars
Oh wait, no, is it heartbreak on the chest?
I saved it
I saw women were less immature than men
No
I was gonna draw
a kuchi or a woman giving birth
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
I literally don't know what the fuck
I'm doing right now
There we go
They need this
Oh my god, I have time
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
What are you doing?
What?
And then
Pen pals
Quick, quick, quick
I'm running out of time
Oh my god
This is okay
These are light ones
I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying
I got it, I got it
These are light ones
I saved it
I think I did a good job
This is the best I got
I ain't got nothing
No
You know what?
Why do I feel like
This is a really specific reference
And I don't know if anyone's gonna get it
But there used to be
A little flash game
Where your guy was on like a snowboard
I love that game
I know what you're talking about
Someone who literally just drawn that
Literally this is perfect
That's it, that's the drawing
Someone says lane raider
Oh I thought we're just called
lane
What is bear pantsu?
I thought people were asking me
To draw a bear wearing underwear
I was like what the fuck is wrong
With you guys
Cause he had big old pants
That were fancy
You know the story
I might make that up
Hydration check girl
You don't want your balls to shine
Okay
You know the story
Some water
He's drooling my balls
He had no hair color
Let me do that
Do you have a beard? I don't know
I drew something
Yeah you're right
I don't really know how to do that though
Can I zoom in?
No
Yeah
Someone said bear braid
Braid is pantsu
Wait what happens
No fuck I didn't mean that
Who drew ball sacks everywhere
It's not you shivy
I only see boobs
No I didn't draw a ball sack
I got it
Who's whispering
I have no idea
What?
There is whispering some like
Evil incantations
I'm sorry
That's not nice
It was definitely Azura that drew the ball sack
100%
Why do I feel like this is a lie
No I didn't draw it
I'm really drawing over it right now
If you guys didn't know
Azura's ears actually have
Gold little jewelry
On the end of them
Pimped out with jewelry
It's like not a vanity thing
It's like gifts
Going for her first
Bike ride
Isn't cheating to erase
Aw fuck it is
Isn't it cute
So if you didn't know
When a women
When a women like tates chat
Here we'll have a
It goes through the fabric
So they'll be like a big lady
Oh she's so happy for her
I know this isn't a piece
That looks terrible
Get rid of that
Oh my god
What am I doing with my life
I was trying to talk about lactation
Duh
This was right before she said
Chocolate that was correct
Milk
Someone's getting a phone call
I thought you were drawing a cute bunny face
Nah they have some titties mate
Thought I can see
I have saved
I have single handedly saved the stream
Probably
This is supposed to be it
The liquid
That's cheating
I know what I wanted to draw
That's nothing
Fine
I don't even know what to draw for my own drawing
I started it and I'm gonna finish it
It's me
Fucking mental
I don't know
I'm already pooped from this
It's the old Mac
Okay
I would talk
But it takes so much brain power
To do this and talk
Talk
Kiss your little
My cats are fighting
Stop
This is a net
Ah
I don't know what I'm doing
Yeah
That's a pretty good net
I think I need to grab it
How do you spell squelch
Squelch
Yeah
Yeah I am
Is it the Amazon?
Oh my god
Is it the reverse Amazon position
And the girls looking
What are you drawing?
What are you talking about?
Reverse Amazon
Is it like eBay?
Yeah
That's definitely what she's talking about
Can they break it?
Oh my god
Does anybody need to take a quick break
Before
I'm ready
Let's do this
That was yours
Okay
Aww
Oh my god
Okay
Someone okay
Oh
It's the same
It's the answer
Oh that's so good
What do you mean you're a bad artist
That's a very good little bear
That's beautiful
He got a boner under the blanket
And everything
Oh yeah
Oh it's the Arthur
Beautiful
Okay
What else could I draw for this?
Aww
Oh
Okay
Uh
Bye
Oh
I like it
I deserve a smoker
I'll put it now
Wait, no the eggs
Oh my god
I saved them
I lied
I didn't save the screen at all
If I don't see a snail
Oh my god
That's so cute
Aww that's so cute
Aww
I love it
I love you flings
Oh my god that's so cute
Aww
That's me
And then there's
I was like get my brain
Get my brain
Get mine broken
Aww
Oh my god
Oh
Okay
Yeah that looks cute
I'm just gonna write more
That's point
Aww
That's so cute
I draw me and the boys
Aww
That's amazing
Literally me
That's me
That's mine
Oh my god
That's so bad
I can't show that
I see
We'll do me and the boys
Okay
That's so good
Why the mono bro
Wait
Oh
Aww
Wait
I drew this little game
Oh this is like Rain Raider
Aww
Aww that's good
That's creative
Aww
Aww I like that
That's really cute
I love that
And me
Aww that's cute
I told you
I know you
Lama Chuba for Jentu
Oh that's cool
I'm gonna say that's a good one
And then I saw the thing on the right
Aww
That's cute Marcy
You didn't
I see you learning how to ride a bike
Aww
What the fuck
Aww that was good
Aww that was so fucking good
Ended up being the most innocent
That was good
Oh my god
Help
I can't breathe
Oh no
This is what he's like to be in VLR
So like you're giving birth
I don't figure out what icebreaker it is
Icebreaker is kinda boring
What are we doing
Wait
Icebreaker is kinda boring
Yeah it's boring
Can I cancel it
If you wanna cancel it
How do I cancel
Wait are we doing this
Or are we canceling it
I don't know
What is happening
Oh there's a fucking ad
You've got an ad?
I'm making another room
Okay
Alright
Where is my
John Snow and Sansa Stark
John Cena
Oh wait no you're coming back in
They still advertise
Wait so do we have a new
Name lobby
Yeah this is one of seven
Wait what is happening
I don't know what is happening
Somebody else make a lobby
It's not the greatest but we can just play it
No somebody else make a lobby
I refuse
Do we have a new lobby or not
Somebody else make it because
I made a new one
Everyone hate the asset
Hate the game
The garlic phone window
Okay hate it first
And then someone make a new one
I can't make it because my connection is dog
I'll do it
Okay the Emmy proven what a big girl she is
That was so fucking weird I'm sorry
That was so fucking creepy
I'm so sorry
Thank god we do not have people
Sorry it's so chaotic
I don't know why there's two of me on the screen
When I hate that
So we are opening in your lobby
Emmy just put up a new one
Show us a link in the description
Okay okay
I sent it
Okay understood
So yes
Let me open the link
Oh there we go nice
I've got a picture
Okay
Okay is everyone here
I'm here
Okay which one do you want to play
Knock off is fun
Because it's like duper
Try to replicate the drawing
Oh yeah do knock off
Do knock off that looks good
Okay
So you make it a pretty drawing
And then it becomes hell
Why are we supposed to draw
Anything you want
Anything
No no no not you
Maybe not anything for you
No no
Please give us something I'm being put on the spot
My mains going blank
Okay hold on let's do a campfire
Let's do a campfire
We can't see
I'll draw
I'll draw should be
Yeah
Should we all just like draw somebody
Oh
No I'm joking I'm joking
I was like oh I'm kind of locked in
Sorry sorry
I've decided to draw one of us
That I have already said out loud
I don't know what to draw
No I'm like that too
Don't put me on the spot I don't know
I don't even know what to draw
Put me on the G spot
Oh one of you guys so I'm gonna choose
On the spot
You want me to draw that
Oh this is terrible on a mouse
That one's actually funny
Can I draw the
How much time do we have I'm like
Can I draw the whole gang again
You have quite a bit of time with this one
Okay hold on
What the fuck is this one
That's not how the strawberries look
How the fuck do you draw something
Sitting down oh my god I'm having a stroke
And not a good kind
What on earth
There's a good kind
I'm supposed to be a strawberry
I'm gonna
This is close enough
Oh my god
I want to draw harmony
I can't draw like this
Wait it has kind of like
His neck at the end
We need to draw a devilish hat
Fuck
I don't know what to fucking draw
Get creative nerds
Jeez it's not that
I'm doing that
Okay miss artist
I'm playing that
I'm literally
It means like I'm just gonna draw myself casual
And it comes out with like this fucking banger
Of a commission it would probably cost like
500 dollars to do
And she like bangs it out
And I'm like oh my god
She's like hee hee
I'm gonna make a vtuber model hee hee
I'm gonna ask you
I wish I could
I wish I had a finger
Nerval talent
Speaking of that someone sent me a fucking marshmallow
They were like thank you for not tying down
Your talents
To the designs that you assigned them
And they can be more themselves and I'm like
Yeah well why would I do that
I was like
I don't know why I feel like it's such a basic
Things what the fuck do I need to draw next
A bleeding heart
Yeah we're more
So like building upon the characters
Rather than
Changing everything
Cause in
Someone rated the vtuber
They were like the only thing that would have been it better
Is if you let them design their models
Like from the start I'm like
Bro it took me a fucking year to get here
Like oh my god give me a fucking
I don't think so
It's never ever to
Draw and rake
A vtuber model
You can ask Amy
She knows how to do it
It's a lot of work
Oh my god
Yeah there's only a select few corpos
That will let you do that
Oh shit
Man this is rough
Usually ones that have like artists in house
Yeah
We just
This is so bad
Most companies
If not all of them
Say for you
Will have pre
Pre-made
So it's not actually standard for people to choose
Yeah it's really not
Yeah
That's why it's usually like cast for the roles
You have to fit the character
To the thing more
Oh
It's magic
You know
There
What the fuck is that stuff
It looks like an abomination
Oh no
Replicated
What is this
Fuck
Why do you guys have average shit
Okay
Now we have to draw it
Are we ready
No
I guess I have to be
I just
I have to be ready for it
Even if I'm not
It's okay
Just draw it your way
Yeah
Very nice
I've already forgot
Which position everyone was in
This is so bad
Sorry
I would talk more but this takes so much brain power
To do this
I'm so brain dead
Like
I'm reading chat
I'm reading everything
But I'm not responding
I'm so sorry
I can see everyone
I'm just really in this
I feel like I'm just
Fucking losing it
Oh my god
I forgot
There was a shorter time
That's far too short
This is why it's chaotic
Why was the other one longer
I don't remember what
I didn't want to do that
Oh my god
What
Did someone draw Shiba in jail
Okay
I don't know what it was
Oh shit there's like no time
Fuck the time
We draw this as fast as we can
Oh fuck
No
Not like this
Shit shit shit
Can't remember what it looked like
Fuck
Is there supposed to be someone in a pirate boat by the way
Cause I don't think I saw it
There's supposed to be a person in it
There's already gone
There's a person
It's supposed to go really fast
So it's
Oh my god
Okay
That's easy enough
Oh it's already have
Okay
Gotta go fast gotta go fast
Gotta go fast
Faster faster oh fuck
Faster faster
Faster
Oh shit
Oh my god I am so sorry
Come on
Faster
Oh
Okay okay okay
Oh please
Why is there no black
Oh no no
Okay okay okay okay we can do this
We can do this
Okay okay okay okay
Let's go let's go let's go
Don't panic don't panic
The great part is that we are all panicking
No no no no
Please
Give me more time
What even is that
Okay this is easy
This is easy
This has to be
Easy
Easy easy easy
Let's fucking go
Man this looks like shit but oh wow
Oh fuck
I mean
That's close enough
Oh my god
That was rough
Oh
Oh my god
That's amazing
I love this
Oh my god
How does her have all that time
Okay
I did not have any time for that
Yeah I was like this is Mr. Mittens
At least
At least it stayed a cat
That did a little campfire
With all of us together
That's so fucking cute
That was supposed to be
We are doing a sacrifice
Sacrifice
The dog
Oh we are arguing about the fire
The angry face
I can't
That's so good
At the end of the day we are all just
Okay this is good
This stayed
Yeah
That's perfect circle
That was a good easy game
He's getting more and more depressed
What is she doing
She's not in jail
She's at the cage
I thought she was in jail
Okay that looks like it
She is under arrest
I love this
He's still got the hooves there
Help
That's fucking amazing
She broke FGO by the end
Honestly
He broke it
He's free
Oh
It's one piece
I was like why the frick
Are we just a parent shit
I was like was someone supposed to be in the boat
I was like
Oh no
Just getting
Just getting ugly
Oh my god
I fucking can't
That looked like a fuller punch
Oh
She's shooting her piss
Wait that's supposed to be me
What
The piss will revive him
Oh
Oh my god
That was so good
One more
Which one
Give us one more
One more
What when have we not done
I don't know
All the actions are a mystery
Drawing incidences are hitting during the game
Secret
Okay
I've never done that one before
We'll try it
Last run boys
Last run
What I can't see what I'm writing
Oh secret
How am I supposed to know what I'm writing
Wait what
Huh
Yeah
Oh no wait you run out of freaking words
Oh bro
I can't erase my sense
I don't know
What is this
Oh my god
What is this it disappears
Oh we can't see what we're drawing
What
Okay we'll draw fast
What the fuck
Okay
Hold on
I don't know I think
I'm gonna just guess
Oh no
What it is where it is
Oh god
What the fuck
Oh no no
I'm gonna try to draw
Why is it so hard to draw with a bone
Ah
I need food
These are the past ones
Can I
Can I go backwards does it work like that
I didn't give you legs
Oh sugar
I think A.C. is somewhere there
Get out
This is
I have no idea what I drew
I can't know what those are
What is this
Okay
Okay I spelled that all wrong
No
I didn't finish
What the fuck
What
What does that even mean
What the fuck
I was gonna say
Okay
Oh fuck
I don't know what else to draw
That's exactly what I drew
I think
This is a vine reference
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing
Oh fuck
I locked in
Did I give
Wait did I give them bodies
I don't think I gave them bodies
Oh my god
I don't know
I'm taking a shot in the dark
Where so you know
What that is gonna be interpreted as
And will I stop the creative flow
Do you
Stop
No Amy's got a hoodie here
Oh sugar
I put juice on her
What the fuck
I don't even know
What the fuck I'm doing anymore
I'm fucking dying
What is this
Two feet of
What
What is happening
What is this
Someone had a stroke
I hope you're feeling okay
Make sure you hydrate
Fuck I didn't have enough time
To write it
Oh man how do I even draw this
This is
That's the tongue
And then this is
Literally everything
Wait
This is so difficult
Fuck am I drawing
You need like motion swipes as well
And a little arrow to indicate
Yeah
I don't know what I'm doing
Yeah there we go
I think I drew it correctly
A little bit of lipstick
Cute
I don't know
I just drew anything
I don't know what I'm doing
I can't wait to see
The end of this
Yeah this is going to be
Something else
This is going to be fucking insane
What's going on in the ceiling
Oh I need to draw it on the ceiling quick
Oh I think I just got that
Oh god oh boy
I'm so scared of what these look like
Same
Oh my god
What the fuck
It's the end of the TikTok
TikTok
Oh my god
Oh you're talking
I completely missed the bodies
Oh my god
I was going to write even being cooked
I was like
I looked like she was on a stick
That's rotating
Oh
I feel so hot
That's everything
This girl is my child
Oh that's why you were humming
Indiana Jones
I was like where did that come from
I was trying to write
Cowboy but I didn't
Oh that's so adorable
That's so adorable
Oh it's Emmy
Wait
What is this
Draw it in white
Oh colors
I used the color black
And I used red as well
And orange
What
What is this
What the fuck
No
No cow
I can't read
This is beautiful
No cow
Hey
I like this girl
She's like
Is that all
Oh my god
Oh
I used the fucking eraser
That's why you couldn't fucking see it
How did we get back to boobs
I don't know how you managed that
Honestly
Well
That potato was really bad
Aw
Awesome
You were number one
Oh is that a 3D concert
Pee Pee's not number one
Oh my god
Oh no
I think it is short
Oh my god
That's amazing
That's what we got there
Your mom called me
Oh no
I forgot to give up
You're so sick
Oh no
My cheeks hurt
Same
My jaw hurt
Okay okay
Glad we could
No
Shit
I just went over by a train
Oh my god
Somebody download that one
That's fucking amazing
That's so fucking funny
I love this
Glad I got permission
Glad I got a train
I know it's a premium car
They got the premium pass
AC at the convention
That trains me
Tag yourself
I'm the ropes
Tying Amy to the tracks
Oh my god
I'm not gonna
Endure the girls to anything more
Cause our faces are ready to fall off
After that
Is anyone in the stream
Are you doing a stream right now?
I need to pee really bad
I'm gonna jump out of the call
Of course you need to pee
I'm announcing my new piss off
I know
I'm going to jump out of the call
And do a little zatsu
Then I'll redirect into Yuzuru
I'm a balloon star though
I might play
Do you guys want me to
I might play some call the lamb
If someone does a pop up stream
Just tell me
I'll talk to my refunds for a bit
Thank you so so much all members and dolls
For this hilarity that ensued
After such a miserable start
It's such a miserable start
To power wash her
Shack myself from laughing so hard
We already know
Asus panties are soaked
So let's not
And Emmy probably
No
Alright let me sniff
Let me sniff
Don't do the sniff test
Rather pungent my dear
Wait for me to just come out
You have to take a test
She just disintegrated
Oh my god
Right I'm gonna jump out of the chat
Thank you so much
We'll be doing collabs next week
With each other so look out for that
And I'll jump out of chat
Thank you so much my darlings
My daughters my girls
I'll talk to you very shortly okay
I love you my daughters
That was fucking chaos
I don't know why there's two of me either
Bruh
I mean honestly too for the price of one
Why is there two
No that's just the one I actually use
Why is there two of me
I wonder if it's picking a game
Did I even have a chatting screen
Oh I do
Thank god
Did I even have this asset
Oh that's a lot of chatting
Oh my goodness
Oh sorry
I really badly need to go for a pee
Is that okay if I can go for
A pee
Yes
And then we'll come back and we'll do some chatting
I need to catch up on some
I'm pretty sure someone don't know the stuff
Oh my goodness
That was so fun
After the abysmal
I kid you not
The abysmal freaking star
Oh
Right give me a few minutes
I just need to go pee okay
Are you squinting me right now
How did you manage to end this insanity
Bro
We are not
Beating the peeler allegations
I do not want to start up the
Kaka allure allegations
I'm already done
I'm already done with that
Right I'm going to very quickly go for a tinkle
I will be back in a second
Please enjoy my background music
I'll just turn it up a little bit so you can enjoy
To its maximum
I'll just be a minute
Literally the toilet is right outside the room
Music
Let me catch up on the notifications I missed because I think I
would like to apologize insanely for the immense delay on getting us started so
I'm literally like starting over my words in anger towards power washers and why did
I just hear a pop noise that wasn't me I just heard a pop like a what was that is it foodie
maybe I don't know I'll close foosie check foosie check thank you bejinger I was gonna call
you bejinger sorry thank you bejinger for the 10 gifted anonymous thank you for the 10 11 out of 10
best stream yeah it was so scoffed like it was so scoffed bejinger with the two back to back super
this is round one I don't know if I can live through this stream sweat honestly and then how
did you mention it this is sanny that was crazy I'm pretty sure someone signed up for membership
hold on I need to go hunt it down um uh what the fuck my ASMR videos got 5000 views
that's shit trending um the garlic phone was such a good recovery brove honestly
we so we showed up all of us really can voice chat for an hour we didn't expect anything to go wrong
but the problem with power wash simulator if you haven't played through the damn campaign
it won't let you play multiplayer which is absolutely stupid I'm sorry that's actual stupid
and they better change it right membership by the pope
oh we use giggling did you enjoy that thank you so much for the tip reluctantly saying did you
actually enjoy it I was like having a good time I really enjoyed it you broke 5k oh my god I have
five videos look at this goober acting like cheese at fault for stuff it doesn't matter it was all
worth it for ac's laugh can like cure you like if you're like in the the gutter ac's laugh is so
precious thank you for the tip tharia or tharja I haven't laughed that hard in ages oh I'm so glad
how is um can I see recent members please youtube show me recent members
oh no I don't think it's gonna show me recent members
seve samurai dr mill minnam lucky the lucky 13 kjik kjik daemon green oreo doc blank
117 and donavon donavon hello thank you so much for the membership I'm so sorry if I can't see your
membership it doesn't oh wait I can wait this is from all the stream no it's not that can't be
that's not right black watch bubble mount uh how strange I don't I don't know why it's not showing
anyway 500k more go munkas um yes I owe you guys a lot of ASMR um now that I am monetized I can
upload I was crying laughing oh I'm so glad I haven't laughed that hard in ages oh
um
yes I now owe you five celebratory ASMR videos I will work on it and I will identify I will put in
the crew the thumbnail like 1000 sub celebration 2000 sub so you can tell what like what's supposed
to just be like a standalone like meme ASMR video versus like uh an actual like thank you for uh
achieving me uh these subscribers so yes special thank you to anyone who does subscribe um and
take a take a like into me and tolerate the old accent and do apologize quite harsh sometimes
uh hope to hear more golem ASMR uh probably on twitter I have quite a few good ear licking
videos that'll go on twitter because youtube's terms of service is sadly updated or being stealth
updated and something is going on with ear licking and breathing in particular I have a sniffing
video coming out soon and it may or may not be limited uh something rather odd going on a
youtube headquarters but they don't want to publicly say it because ASMR is a one of the most
I think it's like they're in their top 10 searches so I'll be curious to see what uh transforms
accent isn't too harsh it's buttery smooth I tolerate I can hear pops did you hear that pop
is it garthik phone is that what that pop is oh it's garthik that's what it is
literally I'm like what what is that pop it's garthik um yeah you should be in dumb stop breathing
your heart let yeah I knew there was a pop I thought it was going freaking mental there I was like what's
going on oh my god the girls recovered that so well thank goodness she be uh had played garthik
phone before that's the first time I've ever played it that was so fun freaking icy seems to
be our muse we were like drawing icy icy icy I wonder if it's because because she's so recognizable
with the blue ears and short blue hair that just makes her like so easily recognizable
and then that's why we kept drawing her over and over again og suns kept getting mentioned
I did get a marshmallow from an og sun that was like thank god for thank you for giving me icy
like I'm so happy and I'm like oh I told her about it and so whoever og sun sent me that I do
I do relay messages to the girls um you know I told them I've been getting quite a few marshmallows
recently of people thanking me for picking them and it's like no no no no no it's all their work
it's their hard efforts it's their enthusiasm um and they applied do you know how many people
lurked and didn't apply because they didn't want to be the first in gen one basically um
um so yeah give up give up for the girls for doing it because they they were doing
fucking amazing um yeah blue small girl equal w it's because icy is canton hey stroney how can
I join your membership there should be a join button and if there's not then I think you need
to be on pc that's my only thing um I do have big stream tomorrow I just have wee streams today
the reason I have wee streams is because I'm trying to catch up mersey's done her monetization
so she can now upload her meme ace oh well I'll upload it on her channel she can unlist it at
any time um that's not a problem uh um what was that I thought I've just distracted myself
oh uh my streams yes I think I'm doing runescape tomorrow
yes okay we have an endurance stream tomorrow so if you've not had enough of mom our mommy
uh freaking other v-tubers are calling me mommy too I'm like yeah damn my influence is spread just
like my in the ASMR booth huh man in the ASMR booth uh stroney I am actually supposed to be blonde
or I'm a ginger because I'm Scottish in me you'd be called a ginger because your your hair's orange
so you're a ginger and to Scottish people but I don't think other nationalities like really say
ginger you thought you were blonde you're supposed to be orange like a pumpkin emi you're a pumpkin
you're my you're my little pumpkin emi but she is so blonde wait is she actually but my hair is
blonde wait am I going crazy am I colorblind but emi's ginger that's not blonde you've got a little
pumpkin hair I've shown you your concept though I mean I guess you could say like your hair is
top of your head is quite blondish I'd say your ginger ginger people have red hair don't they
gin that's what ginger people are ginger people have orange hair like you that's what ginger
voice you're a ginger emi you're a ginger emi yeah you know maybe maybe this is like cultural
different thing but you're ginger in the Scottish eyes it's kind of a strawberry blonde her hair
strawberry blonde the way I see it I thought it was orange myself yeah red hair it really is just
orange yeah I was gonna say you're not like dyed box dyed red hair I think I'm giving emi a complex
over this oops because my hair's got more reddish tint to it um to differentiate me from you
because obviously we we both didn't want ginger hair I've got like a watermelon let's say someone
explained it and there's that watermelon me strawberry has lost the plot once again honestly
I didn't concept you the with your color scheme I just went with it but your orange you're definitely
orange slash ginger in your concept or if you want to take a peek at it again um I don't have it on me
at this point in time oops um I prefer emi she's just discovered she's a yinya oh my wee emi oh dear
getting main fricked right now why would you blonde as yellow is it no I'm like I'm great
are you colorblind or am I colorblind one of us is colorblind in this conversation emi
because it looks too toned I am well the top half is blonde and then it blends into orange
yeah because of the pumpkin dick uh uh design of your at the ends of your hair
I see accidentally closed her obs and forgot to enter stream
um I don't have access to her account on this pc
are you squid me right now oh by the pope here's a way to think about it emi looks like a pumpkin
strony looks like the twister ice cream with green and red yeah I'm twister ice cream I'll dm her hold on
um I mean you know give me one minute I'm gonna go shut down ac stream I give me
one minute refunds are freaking I can't give me a minute I'm shutting down ac stream
um
it's ac stream shut down now
oh the things you have to do when you're a vtuber mommy you have to go shut down their stream
for them because they're goofy goobers yeah that's a shuttle okay so um what an adorable
polar bear it's done yes it should be because I I went on her account oh to be a youtube mommy
wow mommy is back mommy is certainly back uh thank you for that tip thrive uh or thrive job
there's a way to think about it yes okay that's uh icicles stream shut down sylvion the lurking
refling thank you for becoming a member I appreciate it member streams do start up next
week not this week this week's kind of locked in I've got a few behind the scenes things that are
coming out soon now that the girls are monetized or getting to be monetized right I'm gonna
check who has booted up their stream or not Azura who goes there by the pool um Azura
it's on oh emmy already changed her stream thumbnail garthik phone copiel
bro screen miracle change your freaking thumbnail great collab today also congrats on 5k you owe us
oh I freaking do thank you boy thank you for the tip and the the kind words on the 5k yeah
brah I'm actually like this sounds terrible and I'm absolutely 100 thankful for anyone who like
subscribes or enjoys the content or whatever um the girls were getting ahead of me which I was
really happy about because I really didn't want to be ahead of everyone um uh but it's freaking
happened and I'm like oh go subscribe to my daughters everyone look in the description right now and
go subscribe but she be just went live I will redirect into Azura because I've actually yet
to redirect into Azura once um so I'm going to make sure I do that I'm just gonna check if there's
any marshmallows um yeah just thank you so much for your patience again as I said for some reason
power washer simulator does allow six people to conglomerate that's not the correct word
to come together to con congregate into one server however the requirements are you have
had to have completed the campaign mode so I was the only one that had done that so I was trying to
get everyone in at once it did not work um and we were like literally at the 20 minute mark and I
was like oh my god we're just gonna have to cancel this and do like guerrilla streams and come back
to this a later time but then she be she be kept me me head on me shoulders and um she said let's
do garlic phone and we could do it because originally we were gonna do that other browser based
one which I can't remember the name of oh but it was like we would have to screen record the discord
and like absolutely fucking not with the absolute shit we take jackbox that's it we would have had to
screen record at that I'm like don't don't even think about sharing that discord the amount of
inappropriate stuff we send to one another do not dare even hover over displaying discord
strani you can stream anything and we'd love every second of it thank you I'm glad I'm glad you agree
we're doing uh I think we're doing endurance uh runescape tomorrow I want to try and get level
70 cooking um we're not gonna do movies tomorrow I was actually gonna do marshmallows tomorrow
whilst we stream for a bit and then do the classic I'll start rambling about anything and everything
and then how we should be able to take over the capitalistic society and hopefully capitalism
eats itself and births a much more yeah you know what I'm saying um I will do that tomorrow so my
voice is gonna be fried my voice is actually fried from the ASMR yesterday um when I was like
roleplaying as AC I don't think AC knows that I was roleplaying as her because she didn't mention
anything of it but I was like like all of that like she didn't none of them knew I roleplayed
and I'm like yeah I should probably stay under the radar because they're like why do you think I sound
like that or something like that the revolution honestly need to see the discord chat it's just
inappropriate it's like I want artwork of me like this I want artwork of me like that oh I want to
do this with the you know the bleeding hearts I want to do this with the pin pals and I'm like
bruv it's pretty weird so much like break free reflin conspiracy stream tomorrow let's go not
exactly but uh someone said they would actually like to do like a full stream so I would have to
plan for it there's quite a few streams I want to do that require preparation time which sucks
because I have hardly any time I do have a collaboration of the girls coming out soon
one big audio which should hopefully boost everyone past 5k I was checking the statistics
and I was like why is AC and Azura not paying out the same levels and it's not because of like
this or that I looked at how badly YouTube was culling everyone it was going for AC's jugular
and Azura's throat like seriously the culling was so harsh I got culled 700 subs one day and AC
got 1500 subs culled on one day which explains why um like because the viewership between us
all is pretty much the same reef anarchy oh I quite like that Rafa Rafa and I see yeah AC and
Azura got hit hard the worst um when we were doing that culling but it's over now the culling has
stopped praise uh the lord because that was just getting so rough honestly um
uh it's really cute that you keep the bibutes to yourself why would I share that
I like it strongy silver hand is absolutely genius you would love to play
2077 I'm certain of it okay okay we'll definitely play it I'm like 99 percent sure
Rebecca's gun is in that game as well somewhere I don't know where but Rebecca's gun is somewhere
in that game snowberries are strong yeah college at world at war zombie mode was like that back in
the day we're not getting culled anymore now that we have content out we're monetized yada yada
yada we're not getting culled anymore so thank goodness for that um because that was getting
pretty rough but tomorrow endurance stream with runescape the day after we're playing crash
bandicoot warped um I'm pretty sure they remastered the game but I think that's eight hours long to
complete it so that's a nice uh it's a longer stream not endurance I think endurance is 10 hours
that's what I consider an endurance stream anything less than 10 hours and I'm like meh
that wasn't really wasn't really uh feeling it the only thing the only thing I don't like about
doing endurance streams is that I have to walk away to go tinkle or get a cup of tea or get some
food like I wish I could somehow do it all in this room so I didn't have to go away and like
me or whatever the icy train joked sladia and they were good um that disappearing game mode
was so fun trying to guess like where to draw next did you like the premium passes around the
og suns next I there I was getting bullied and he was bullying me for my scotch accent I can't I
said a word I think it was og suns because of the way it said I was oh no it was a hegeo or whatever
and she was like oh the way you're saying it I'm like surprise surprise I'm freaking scot but
the girls are such fun like mercy was a while ago like when we kind of just first got started
mercy was like am I allowed to make fun of your accent I'm like yes mercy I sound absolutely
ridiculous I know I sound bizarre it's perfectly fine mercy you can make fun of me you you do not
have to be scared that I'm gonna be like oh my god you said something that's it you're getting a
stealth suspension or something I don't know Scotland whatever it's okay have fun listening
to your accent and pronouncing stuff yeah you're like the way I see things differently yeah I'll
bet you do surprise surprise what the fuck is that ASMR video going well that I uploaded
I've just refreshed and I've gone up a hundred subscribers am I missing something
is someone posted that ASMR video somewhere
or is it just because it's like a complete meme so the way I've recorded that audio I
don't know if you guys have seen that a girlfriend begs you to let her hold the ASMR
and it probably sounds a bit different because I've purposely left in mistakes normally I like
super edit everything as much as possible but why is it picked up so much traction it should
have only got like 1k views you hit the algorithm the vid is close to 4k views you say 4k on my
end it says it's 5.4k views wait hold on I'll screenshot and show you what I see
okay I need to refresh the page so I can get the confetti
whoa that is screen recording please do not screen record that's not nice
um
does that not save
this is what I see so if you've never seen like the behind the scenes of a
an ooo to the video type thing uh this if I can redo this really quickly
did that not save it did uh this is what it looks like when you upload a video
uh it literally says like oh in four hours you've ranked by like your viewers if you have a one
out of ten you get like confetti um an impression click through rate percentage you get like
duration of how long they listen so yeah don't mind if I do I've got quite a few comments to
approve on it though I have them comments uh on approval as you can imagine because I knew
I cannot have an an agency that was a bit uh disoriented no that's not right at all um a bit um
on alternative side you know I knew the girls were gonna get harassment and stuff so everything
for us it shows 3.90 that's very cute
up next someone commented up next girlfriend begs you to let her put donuts on it honestly that's
probably the sequel um that's probably the very valid sequel don't think my comment got approved
yeah the comments are really bugged out
yeah the comments are like super bugged out for some reason when it comes to like needing to
approve them oh my god I'm not used to seeing my my uh extremities I'm not used to seeing my my
personality oh wait no that one wrong one sorry I'm not used to seeing my personality that's so
weird um I just admire in the art for the art honestly um but yes that collab was fantastic
um I did kind of do a little spoiler you know but next week the girls are doing one-on-one
collabs do you want to know who I'm taking on have a guess who you think I'm collabing with next
week from vealer from vealer take again have a gander
me and mersey oh my cat's at the door um I don't know if you can hear it it's good
um I'm playing with mersey and we're gonna be playing a game where we can go
we're gonna be playing goose game together and I'm so excited I have no idea what it's gonna go
like but I freaking love mersey um I was showing my co-worker while I'm watching brov me who just
took off my you cat oh oh so that's what you're seeing is you picked mersey I should have picked
any kind of door we ended up playing in goose game and honking out all the people I've never
played goose game before but I think I think um it's like a puzzler timing type thing so hopefully
I don't get too region as long as mersey can carry me hopefully she's played it before if she's not
played it before then we'll be looking at the snippets and the reef links to help us up through the
game um oh my god goose game yeah you split the first collab by size didn't you yes I did um that's
also how the collab or alternative audios are split for the first time I don't know if people
are gonna like isra and shabby's collab audio there will be some people who are like gonna
levitate but I know it's not for the masses please don't be mad at them be mad at me because it's
what I came up with and I quite like the idea um vealer and yumi plus um soon I can't really
say when but soon um I don't know when we can say when
it's good chaotic okay oh lord the old overwatch meme song is in psd well I was worried about name
and mercy mercy because she had a uh I think I told you I did tell you guys um she was originally
called karam beats uh in few all the way up to development about a month then I was like
I need to rename her this isn't gonna work um I knew it was a bad name but there were so many
developmental issues behind the scenes that kind of left me a bit helpless like I only had myself
to rely on for certain sections and the naming kind of ended up with me um which I can like look back
and laugh at now like that's why like I'm like oh fondle of bosom that's funny or like she be caught
in bottom oh that's funny type thing but at the time like I could cry thinking about like the stress
I was under and I felt like I couldn't like reach out to anyone in the development team side of things
because I was having a really difficult time so karam beat made it all the way through until we
got modest which means is frenched for your dressmaker and mercy if you didn't know her lore
is she's actually a fashion designer which is why her outfit is so out there and is so unique
um because it's handcrafted all that jazz um and um
mercy obviously mercy is a very big overwatch character but there's no vtuber called mercy
and I'm like mm mercy modest sounds so good and especially the yandere element of like the last
thing you'll be screaming for is mercy I think I came up with that in the development team and
like everyone just unanimously agreed there is another sentence we really like for mercy which is
um fear is a top shelf aphrodisiac that came up by largely came up by one of the audio editors so
shout out um to them they just came out with it and I was like yep we're gonna take that thank you
and I think it's in her trailer um because it was such a good sentence uh you nailed the names in
the end oh well I'm glad you agree thank god I'm not naming gen 2 or gen 3 um I don't have to do any
of that gen 2 is getting named uh for me how many people are on the development team so they're not
all listed on the website um I think uh we had a lot of comments like that they were like oh the
the team's so small the team's so this the girls don't have access to the full development team for
safety reasons and the development team do not have access to them um there's quite a lot of um
advisors I guess is the best way to call them um and it's kind of just information fetching think
of it like a fetch quest and uh like a video game just like here can you go tell this person this
deliver this letter it's kind of like that um there's a lot of people who give influence in
overall advice uh some of them are content creators some of them are long-term artists some of them
um are editor the editors give a bit of feedback which is decent the audio editors they're
um but yeah there there's a lot there's no um employees it's all contract based um
and that was one of the feedbacks like oh the company's gonna go under because
how are they gonna pay all these employees don't be so fucking stupid and that was that was probably
one of my most used phrases when violor hadn't started up yet was that phrase whenever I read
something it was like how are you how are you gonna pay all these salaries and all these
medical expenses because you'll have to offer healthcare don't be so fucking stupid seriously
don't be so daft in the head to to genuinely think that it's employee based when it is an
international company dealing with international talents like none of us have fucking met in
real life that's not how it works um like honestly some of the stuff it was like how
are they gonna pay into their pensions don't be so fucking stupid it's obviously contract
based work it's self employment contract based work like oh how are they gonna pay for all the
editors uh when we go to them and commission the job like you think we have editors on on
employee employee salary what so if they if I only give them three audios for an entire month
I'm I'm still gonna give them a full salary don't be so fucking stupid honestly some of the
feedback some of some of the feedback or that would be like the negative feedback do not even
have a fraction of a clue on how to like run stuff and it's the confidence that like to even type
such messages honestly unionize not like 401k benefit yeah like it's like it's an international
company uh what do you mean you expect us to have private healthcare for our employees it's
contract self employment based work oh my goodness oh my goodness like it's okay not to know about
this stuff that's perfectly fine that's different but to wrongly announce and criticize the company
before it had even launched and just to be so blatantly wrong oh it was my favorite
phrase in development just just take a screenshot and like show the development team and be like
oh some of this stuff was ridiculous um so it's been I have to admit it's been bloody satisfying
it's been very satisfying being like yeah we're one weekend 5k subs oh yeah one weekend monetized
oh yeah I have to admit that's been satisfying just to be like because everyone was like oh
one of the biggest feedbacks actually was that uh the girls are gonna get harassed by the development
team or something like that and I'm like don't be so stupid it's so easy not to give any developmental
staff access to the talents and what to do I've done it and it's super easy turns out all you have
to do is be an owl that's it you just have to relay messages to one team to another it's that easy
like honestly some of the feedback was like oh then it'd be so stupid me anyway that's my rant
over and done with thank you for living me to rant for one day what do you mean your
Vtuber agency doesn't have a retirement plan oh literally it was like stuff like that like
I can set the girls up long term and tell them what to do and like this is how I did it and this
is how you should do it type thing um but yeah only one man can harass them exactly like um
I spoke to like another agency owner and they were like oh everyone in their development team
like had to go through um HR training as well as the talents and I was like
I was who literally just like sexually harass each other and the discord and like send in
the front like I was like straight up sending pictures of myself and I'm like this is what I
literally like smile um so yeah the moment you called me a big girl literally I was like how
that was really creepy I'm like why did those words slip past my mouth
going to sleep right at rest well I'm gonna redirect into Azura very shortly um I'm
I'm just yapping for a little bit a little recap um why would the dev team even want to
well it happened in other high profile agencies let's just say um one agency in particular came
out and were like her talent was uh had misconduct with a team member and I was like wait you mean
your team member preyed upon your talent like the way they twisted that I was like oh that's
our that's rough to try and navigate that one mate honestly just shut up and let them go
uh stop apologizing that graphic collab is one of the best tunes I've had in five years
awww strongy love ac love emmy love shebe love azura love velia via lura love but best of all
mommy love free fling love uh hi strongy have you seen the kagaguri one six sale that's out
for pre-order can you put it on throne oh that's very kind of you but I don't think I would get
much use out of it I can't hot glue it unfortunately and I said what I said I want to hear strongy
look at her there's also that popular streamer her editor admitted to jork into yeah that kind of stuff
literally you know how you prevent all of that from happening in an agency have one person
be an owl that's it have one person relay back and forth from the talents to the development team
and that's it that's all you have to do it's super simple and easy but no one seemed to have
figured it out before me so I actually feel pretty proud of myself for just knowing off the bat how
to do that uh huh whenever something bad ish happens you should post a white paper note
some vealers official twitter the tweets wording should be ambiguous and the right on the paper
should be formal looking but tiny so people can't make out what it says from the preview but then
they open it full screen it says nobody's getting suspended and you forgive the girls for whatever
she did bro the girls cannae do any wrong like I'm sorry but like I don't know like ooh they did
a kink that's frowned upon ooh so bad ooh like oh go and just let them play video games and shut
the fuck up honestly anyway um something else to call that is a singular point failure a singular
point of failure just one okay um but they did know how to be an owl but they were too lazy to do that
uh it it it deboggles my mind um how there's not owls in other agencies all you need is a really
basic owl did you know that in magic the gathering there was a creature type called cephalid referring
to humanoid cephalopods I mentioned this because of the because tomorrow on June 14th wizards of the
coasters officially removing them from the game albeit without a public announcement only through
you know funny you mentioned magic the gathering I wanted to get into that when um
I'm no longer busy but I'm not allowed to say it
but they complained about sheebie to whom huh
oh no it's something I don't like better light the beacons honestly it's like
why don't you shut up like I feel like we're all just like on the same page where it's like
just shut up and walk away if you don't enjoy the content it's really no that hard
like I will continue to engage in the content that makes me upset and outraged and then you wonder
why like you've got anxiety you've got depression you've got a fucking array of a list and then you
keep participating in the shit that puts your body into fight or flight because you feel so
passionate about the thing that upsets you like brav just fuck off and see what who what a message is
this and I enjoyed your girlfriend begs you to let it hold it is the mom oh
is someone who's writing poetry and my freaking marshmallow my hygiene is better than a frenchie
is the one manager enough for six talents
well let me reverse the question if you have an agency where the girls do not need to come to you
for approval for streams approval on what they need to do approval for this approval for that
what do you need to manage is my question the only thing was audios was my job but it's no longer
my job because I have an audio manager in place so I don't even have to do that now so my question is
what do the girls need help with because Azura's got her donut on coming up so I'm gonna work with
her one-on-one on that and it's like you don't need a full-time person to come in and manage you
know I don't mean that in a mean way I don't mean to be like I just mean like like seriously if you
are genuinely curious like if you run an agency where the girls need permission for you every single
week when they submit their games to you or like what they want to do that week yeah of course you're
going to need a manager because you've forced that you've forced the hand of needing a manager
running your agency like that if you say you know what girls you are adults I'm going to treat you
like an adult you can decide on whatever you want to do if you need advice you come to me I'll tell
you what I did or what I think would work well for you and yeah it completely negates the need of a
a general manager now if the girls ever came to me and said I cannot think for myself I don't
I want to stream but I can't think that's when I would create schedules for them and notes about
what game I've selected or what zatsu or what theme I can do that you know it's very hands-off the more
controlling you are the more the more headache you're causing for everyone the talents become
insecure in their choices if you're rejecting their schedules and
management itself will start to feel burned out and tired because they're having to abide by these
rules of saying like oh this girl isn't allowed to play this game because of this reason but that
girl that girl's fine she's allowed to do that because of this reason no you're just causing
headache and heartache for no reason these girls that have applied for your agency they
have saw a vision they have saw success in your plan for you to turn around and not let them cook
as the as the saying is is just ridiculous you're just causing upset among all the ranks like if
the girl if the girls ever came to me and said look I'm struggling to pick games guess what I've
already wrote them a guide with loads of listed out games and if that's not enough then guess what
I'll work one on one with them and pick out their schedule and pick games out that I think are
accessible to them or what they'll enjoy I'll do my research like it's really not that hard to
enable your talents it's really not that hard um potentially tech upgrades yes so that's up to
the girl with the 80 20 split so it's just just turning into agency stream again I'd like to I
like talking about the behind the scenes though because I don't mind yes when it comes to technology
so some agencies will take a percentage out of their earnings to put back into technology
we have said to the girls look the split is 80 20 whatever you do with your 80 percent is up to you
and you know if you choose not to upgrade your equipment if you're not satisfied with it
honestly that's not on us you know that's not on us at that point um like I'll say it to their feet
like they already know like the girls are all on the same page if you're getting an 80 split 100
merch sales um and a few other things coming up um yeah if if their technology's bugging out or
they need something new and they don't pay for it themselves look brov brov we did offer a streaming
kit so if the girls needed like basic iPhones for track in or microphones or a pc in someone's case
um yeah we did purchase it on their behalf type thing but yeah mommy is doing so great and good
job as you can hear so glad she caps about all literally I don't know why like any of it should
be a secret it's just like this is how the agencies run I'm sure no one is surprised um
um I love listening to you talk about these things really love getting to see your passion
um it's um like literally like I'm giggling away being like oh I've just turned the ic stream off um
that's wrong but uh sorry there's a ic just added me on timing um
um yeah no I honestly don't mind talking about it oh obviously development took a year and I've
kind of said like one of the criticisms we got was that the girls weren't allowed to pick their designs
it took a year for the models to get here it took a year for the concept or it took a year like
brov in the nicest way I am very aware that idol in lets their talents pick designs and that I can
hear Gimli meowing um pics or designs and all of that we do not have a development team like that
I do not have six model artists and six model rigors on standby at this time at this schedule
that's just not possible for me especially with the way the cut works like if if I were to even
offer that the cut would not be 80 20 that's just not possible in such a budget we would have to pay
special rate Gimli I'm almost finished do you want in the room right right you'll get in the room
sorry let me let Gimli in Gimli in you come
then don't be surprised when I'm talking to myself like a crazy person in the room okay
and don't go in the cupboard right Gimli has pika where she chews plastic you want on my lap
where are you you want on my lap or do you just want to be in the room
what do you want you want on my lap right thank you come on come talk to the reeflings with me
ah since you're meowing your head off look that's them there look there's reeflings there do you see that
they like that I called you Gimli after lord of the rings because you're ginger
and you're a girl are you squid me are you a girl cat Gimli sorry
main and your pet have the exact same name literally she had ginger on her I don't even
know what her original shelter name was they had to give her a name because that's right you were in
a hoarder home weren't you yes you were you had she was in a cat a
you just walked out the room no that's right that's right come here come back on my lap
the reeflings want to see you oh it's my baby girl this is my princess there okay she's on my lap
man hearing you talk about this girl expertly and passionately so great because I can feel my
tism going off like spider said she's just like me for real for real or I can thank you for the 10
um yeah like I honestly don't mind like uh some of the other feedback we got was like oh no males
absolutely nothing's stopping you for opening up a male agency mate good fucking luck for that the
only reason I can do chicks is because I have chick experience isn't isn't that crazy man blowing
concept Gimli isn't it she's currently rubbing my chair right now it's absolute mind blowing
concept where I can't manage guys because I've never made content as a guy my staggering beyond
belief absolutely earth shattering information revealed yeah the only reason I can hire chicks
is because I've got experiences of chick like my god what am I gonna say I did oh yeah just
fucking I don't know what do what games the guys play that girls don't play um oh yeah go play
Tarkov for eight hours like what am I supposed to do I don't I don't what do you want from me
go make your own freaking VTuber agency then like go divided have fun just remember to plan
like double the money whatever money you think it'll cost double it and then add some more because
that's exactly what happened to me um wait strong is a girl oh my god she knows what we're doing no
oh no Tarkov players and shambles I've never played Tarkov but I or like rust but I think
those are very very guy games we'll make her own refling agency with men in black jackets
this is all there was like such random feedback sorry I think oh no she's not she's still in the
room are you okay so my cats are neutered but it looks like she's peeping and she when she
shakes her tail and she just did it there because she thought I was getting up to feed her you've
got dry nibbles down Gimli don't don't make the reeflings think I starve you they're gonna burst
into the house Gimli and it's all your fault and then again I could just burst into the reeflings
house so do you wanna come with me Gimli on an adventure we can go to a reefling and she's now
clawing my chair for attention because she knows that's how it gets me off my chair because I always
work suddenly sleeping strongy yes when I look away my model descents and why is because it's
dark my lips are wiggling so hard I can recalibrate recalibration complete strongy model recalibrate
and yeah see I don't wiggle as much when I sink uh it's pretty dark in this room I ain't gonna lie
she's just trying to give you what you need you starve Gimli no I don't starve why I give her
nibbles before stream after stream and whenever I'm making a cup of tea she always comes and
says hi to me don't you gimme alls she's literally at my pc please do not pull the back plug whatever
you do do not grow an opposable thumb and pull it back to pc right your background song reminds me a
lot of where is my head by the pixels um it's actually um from it's actually bingo highway
sonic os t sonic heroes os t i'm pretty sure mine's bingo highway because it goes ear to ear like
that's the best way I can describe it but um no it's not from fight club but I do love fight club
very much because you know down with the society and all that jazz but uh yes I my payment for letting
you hold Gimli what are you looking for she's scooting her butt across the car no not her butt
like no she doesn't have worms she's clawing the carpet and moving her whole body across it
but she's scooting over my carpet my payment for letting you hold my as I go tinkle will be
deep oh a bit of a bit of french kissing
okay I definitely cannot read the rest of that message out loud that's outrageous Gimli you're
clawing my chair the reflins are talking to me I have to divide my time between you and the
reflins okay and now is refling time yeah yeah oh she's got to be clawing the air because she's
doing air biscuits she's so happy to be in this room because I'll never let her in it I will 100%
do fight club watch along again I want to beg whimper reflin
hi strongy I hope you don't mind me saying but find it hot when you rant and get angry
what are you like because my accent comes out more when I'm angry
I forgot to say I may not shower that often but I use soap and water when washing my hands
I always soap and water after using the toilet I'm not like those idols who run back to their
stream without washing hands some of them are so fast I ask them did you wash your hands and
they say yes but I know it sucks they wash their hands I have to pee I'll be watching
you via lure talent and you with a suspicious squint a squid squint Gimli you're cutting up my
chair am I gonna have to send you out the room you acting right I'll let you outside in the garden
she wants to go in the garden right I will redirect into Azure don't chew that stop chewing plastic
right out there's too much plastic in this room she's currently chewing my thigh out I'll be out
in a minute okay I'll redirect into Azure she's not chewing my freaking thigh thigh plastic
yeah she came from a hoarder home and I'm with like 40 other cats so I think she
unfortunately developed a bad habit of chewing things she shouldn't because there isn't a lack of food
um she's meowing she's so mad at me she thought I was coming out the room with her hold on hold
on let me redirect into Azure Gimli you've been so patient with me these like tongues of other
streams she's been so patient um okay my thigh height she's like mom give me attention she honestly
is adorable right I've saved the redirect into vizura I am so sorry my cat is literally calling
me away from stream I wish I could have answered more however it's an endurance runescape streams
tomorrow please don't be afraid to join me in old school runescape I will tell you Gimli I'll be a
second I'll tell you the world and um she's goes fucking nuts I will tell you the world and we can
stream step on runescape and we can do lobster runs or whatever I've actually got a ton of fish
in my inventory to cook I'll get that all cooked up because I don't want to let that waste because
reefland's directly gave me that um and I will try and end on like level 70 we'll see how far we
can go I won't be watching a movie on this one but on the next ones I'll tell you what movies
we'll watch I think we'll do maybe John Wick John Wick has four movies though which is quite long
um can't wait for more of you strongy thank you uh yes you've got 12 hours of me tomorrow
as long as I get an adequate rest because my sleep has been absolutely terrible um but yes
thank you so so much reeflings I had absolutely amazing time with indulge sorry for starting
so late but we actually did have an amazing time drawing all of those and AC's laugh is so precious
right let me just make triply sure I'm reading it uh Azura uh details hold on oh no oh no oh man
this can't be this is a forgiveness sake I'm under I'm in the wrong setting surely right details
customization Azura right there we go right please enjoy lovely Azura Duly as she plays
Stardew Valley if you'd like to fall asleep to her absolutely lustrous voice you're more than
welcome to because I was saying to her all your streams end up being ASMR because of how beautiful
your voice is um and she was giggling away right thank you so so much reeflings I will see you
tomorrow in during stream we will get into it I will be much deeper into any topics of conversation
um because I'm sure you like it deep but um we will come back tomorrow same time
usual time if you will um please don't worry if you can't stream tonight we will be in a
free-to-play server okay Gimli I'm coming right bye guys bye reeflings love you bye bye